[Music]
seahawks had one job and two candidates
for that job it came down to carlos hyde
and davonte freeman they put the offer
out there devante freeman didn't want it
hyde took it a one-year deal worth up to
four million the key phrase there is up
to until we know the triggers we don't
know what he has to do to make the four
million what we do know is devonta
freeman won't be playing for the
seahawks will be playing for anyone else
reports suggesting he'll sit out the
year if he doesn't get the offer that he
wants
reports suggesting maybe he'll retire he
reacted to that angrily on twitter last
night in a now deleted tweet saying that
he's not retiring kill that retirement
bleep and f all y'all was his parting
shot on the tweet that was later deleted
he's been hanging around sims a little
bit too much look chris here's the
bottom line devonta freeman's a guy
who's made a lot of money playing
running back he's the point in his
career and his life where they're not
going to pay him
the way that they used to pay him the
sun has set on devante freeman's high
dollar seasons he has to ask himself am
i willing to keep playing if i'm going
to make a lot less than what i'm
accustomed to and i think most running
backs are going to go through that at
some point it's not like frank gore's
getting big money to continue his career
adrian peterson's not getting big money
to continue his career so davonte
freeman has to ask himself how much is
it worth it for me to continue to play
football and right now it looks like
whatever's being offered it's not worth
it
no you know and you know again and and
devonte freeman who of course had a
great start of his career but let's and
let's not forget he hasn't rushed for a
thousand yards since 2016. so i don't
know why he thinks he's going to be able
to hold team's feet to the fire like
they're going to be like oh man we gotta
have you oh no here's 10 million dollars
we were wrong no that's not going to
happen and yes you mean to what you're
saying mike devonte fireman's got to
figure that out you know he's one of
those guys that plays the position like
he's like ezekiel elliott or derek henry
but he's five hun you know five eight
two hundred and six two hundred and
eight pounds something like that so i
would think his body is you know it's
it's beat up already um so he is gonna
have to make that judgment on whether he
wants to continue to play for whatever
the league minimum is for somebody
that's playing that long in his career
or whatever it may be and just and
basically get incentives yeah that's
what it's going to have to be until he
kind of reproves himself and then maybe
he can get more some guaranteed money
for the next contract or something like
that
he added in that deleted tweet that he
has 10 more years left in him i think
that is negative goes right here but but
but here's the thing chris what he needs
to do is accept the fact that if the
offers aren't where he would like them
to be go somewhere and be part of a
platoon system be part of a revolving
door a rotation which will extend your
career if you're not being overused
you're going to be able to get yeah
that's a question how brightly do you
want the candle to burn he's burned it
brightly so far now he's at the point
where maybe you want to go a slow burn
and play longer make less but extend
your career
seattle seems like it would have been
the right place you know you get to be a
running back and a team that's most
likely going to be a winner this year
going to be in the playoff conversation
we know they like to run the ball they
have all the running backs you talked
about i'm shocked he didn't take that
deal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports